hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today we're
restoring an axe head now this is a
project I've been wanting to do for a
long time I got this awesome axe head
here look at this thing man it's hand
forged old it's got this cool design I
would love to bring this back to its
former glory and just really have a
really custom awesome accident to use
when can be you know we're just going to
kind of see what we can do
[Music]
yeah I don't know if you can see this
but there's some writing there Hunt's
crucible something like that huh I can
look that up and see what that is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
taking the Knicks out of the blade and
I'm going to start working on the edge
it's kind of painful I'll just grind it
off the entire point and starting to
fresh so it's kind of sad just taking
whatever edge was left and completely
obliterating it all right so for the X
handle I really wanted something special
and check that out this is a wood called
barato it's a South American hardwood
this thing is gorgeous it's got some
epic grain in it 1 and 3/4 by about 2
and 3/4 2 inches right there 24 inches
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
okay so I'm looking for where I can see
light and I can see one high spot on the
right side I'm going to use them to take
it out well this is taken forever but
there we go it's on tiny bit of play in
it but I'm pretty proud of it
[Music]
Oh
Oh
and it just feels great get my second
wind on this project so now I'm going to
start sanding down the handle I've done
as much with the angle grinders I dare
do now I'm going to do the rest by hand
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so when I cut out the template I screwed
up a little bit um I did not flip the
template over so if you look they're
exactly the same which is a problem
because then one side is finished in one
side is not so I have to flip it like so
but now it doesn't match because it's
not symmetrical top to bottom
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh like butter Oh
[Music]
[Music]
it won't splice oh
ah I like this axe
this was the night that I had so much
fun with this project it was just a ball
I hope you enjoyed this video too
thanks for watching we put out new
videos every week so don't forget - ah -
the outdoor boys YouTube channel